THE PERFECTION LINE
PUSH HAULA.
VERY AGGRESSIVE FOR DOWN LOW.
THE CENTERING PASSINTOPROBLEM
GETTING THE PUCK UP THE ICE.
THIS BROWNS POWERPLAY.
THE LAST FEW DIFFICULT STOPS. A.
LAYS OUT IN FRONT OF
THAT PUCK OUT.
GIROUX, READY TO GO ON THEIN
THIS ONE.
THE FLYERS SHOWING OFF BLUE LIP
ALL WRAPPED UP.
COMES OUT IN FRONT.
AND THEY SCO NICE PASS.
HE ELEVATES THE PUCK ON SET FOR
SHOT.
DEFLECTION.
SCORE. TO RISTOLAINEN.
THEY SCORE.
HE PUNCHES I IIT D THE PUCK.
COYLE, DROP PASS.
HALL TRYING TO GET IN  THE BOAR
ATKINSON.
BRASSARD.
TO PROVOROV.
TO GIROUX.
HE SCORES.
[ HE BURIES IT.
AND THERE'S BRASSARD
DEBRUSK.
SMITH TAKES
THE SHOULDER OF JONES.SET FOR
.
RIGHT THERE.
THE PASS.
HE JUST THE AIR.
MAKES THE PASS TO ZBORIL.
ABLE TO GET